we are taking calls today at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 let's take our next call I believe
we've got another Massachusetts caller
if I'm not wrong caller what's your name
and where you're calling from
hey David my name is Mike and I'm
calling from Worcester Massachusetts
today with quick line of questioning for
you and then a short comment I hope
you'll let me get you okay well I just
recently saw a clip a couple days ago of
Obama hosting the World Series
championship winning Cubs at the White
House and making like a quick offhand
joke about how their general manager
Theo Epstein as the man who brought both
the Boston Red Sox and the Cubs out of
the wilderness to Championships might be
a good person to put in charge of the
DNC now I think he was joking but it
does make me wonder if you have any
ideas for potential outside-the-box
candidate that you'd like to see be
nominated for chair of the DNC I don't I
don't currently have anyone and I would
bring proactively suggest I've not put a
lot of thought into that thus far ah
okay yeah but I assume you're not I
Donna Brazile fan I don't think that you
know I personally have liked Donna
Brazile for a very long time but there's
no case to be made after everything
that's happened for her being DNC chair
absolutely not right right she
definitely still has the stink of
corruption on earth at Wasserman Schultz
does doesn't you for lack of a better
term she was wrapped up in the entire
controversy that that involved Hillary
Clinton and there's just you know from a
pragmatic point of view I Donna Brazile
is not the right person definitely
definitely
oh so anyway real quick I just want to
say well I still have you that I'd like
to assure the viewers that a Pats road
trip was not as lame as it sounded on
the bonus show and I think I speak for
everyone when I say that you know I know
13 story here
in there we definitely serve to spice
your show up what story hold on oh even
got a reveal this but I know who this
caller is okay yeah so you know this guy
what hold on a second wait wait wait
let's all call everybody's getting very
excited what story would spice things up
please tell you know this problem is
that hold on is that guys well oh I
think everybody's getting very nervous
which story is it that would be
interesting let me hear from the caller
first I really don't feel comfortable
revealing a any of these stories you
know oh I see you're just saying that
there are stories that would be
interesting the rendition of the drive
was she related she rated you rated yeah
and I think he may have wanted me to
elaborate more on the things that I left
out oh do you have any speculation yeah
all right well listen everybody's
getting really worked up here this
caller has thrown the call calls day
into it into a complete haywire mess
okay listen I appreciate the call we're
gonna dig into this more off the air and
then then we'll follow up all right
caller thanks so much we do have to move
on
Wow so that's the guy that you went on
the infamous road trip with yeah and I
was able to recognize him immediately
from his voice I just thought he
wouldn't bring up the fact that he knows
me right brimming with curiosity yeah
all right well we've got a special team
investigating that later